this spot is money finding the right
spot to forage moss is crucial it's not
just any old mosque we're going forth
we're not gonna come up to this monster
right here and start ripping the roots
out like you rip out grass from a lawn
we're not gonna start doing that to hurt
the tree the bar or the moss we want to
keep everything really intact even
though look this is beautiful moss if it
doesn't kind of pop right off we're not
going to use it okay cuz we want we're
not killing any moss what we're looking
for is the perfect Moss to harvest we
wanted to kind of come off not in little
chunks like this but kind of bigger
chunks longer chunks we don't want it to
come off difficult we wanted to come off
nice and easy so let's find the perfect
moss sarah has her Moss hunting skills
her Moss radar her ma star this is gonna
come up in chunks for sure yeah so we
just come out with a bucket and you have
to gather quite a bit but when you when
you start to take it what you want to do
is just try to slide your hand up
underneath oh yeah look at that that's
beautiful how thick those sliding my
hand right underneath it I'm gonna take
this stick off and see if she can
maintain this sheet and get even more
moss all in one sheet because when we
put it on the roof material you'll see
we want it to cover a large space kind
of a pain in the butt to poke in just a
little bit at a time it's better if you
can have it intact like this and look
it's coming off of a dead decaying
rotting tree and we're not taking this
tree out of the environment these
nutrients are still going into the soil
some people want to kind of criticize
picking moss and I would say that we
consciously do it and we're very
respectful of this moss it's going just
a few hundred feet over that way and
it's gonna live a happy happy existence
and some will grow back here this log
will continue to decay quite nicely yes
you know it's funny
when I first met Jacob the day I drove
up to Washington to shoot his cabins we
were running late the photographer and I
and
kept having a message and say sorry
another hour another hour and you know
by the third time I was like I'm so so
so sorry and he was like oh don't worry
I'm just out here foraging for moss and
never thinking who is this guy
and Here I am you talking about me
foraging for mom you don't want to take
too much from one place babe dude chill
I know what I'm doing my mom scream we'd
like to get a kind of mixture of mosses
we've also got this like Christmas tree
Moss right here that Sara was getting
and we could just in a place like this
this is like a jackpot we really hit
jackpot over here you come over here
this is literally my favorite kind of
Moss this is my favorite kind of Moss
this is this is my favorite kind of mozz
I don't know how to say it it kind of
looks like made in fern maybe that's why
I love it so much because it's it's a
moss that looks almost like a fern and
it has a fern in it look at just right
here in this section that kind of Moss
that kind of Moss that kind of moss did
I count that yeah that kind of moss
Auburn this kind of Moss Moss boss
favorite kind of moss so now we've got a
few kinds we could keep going but let's
bring this on back over to our roof and
start Moss on it
[Music]
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please